lockdowns you've heard they are the only
solution i would like to see a dramatic
diminution of the personal interaction
that we see in restaurants
and in bars more of the country is
closing down tonight
you've heard that anybody who wants
schools to allow students or businesses
to operate or churches to open
just wants grandma to die we direct a
statewide
order for people to stay at home 100
percent
of the workforce must stay home
we need to keep locked down you must
stay at home
we've heard the only way to crush covet
is to end economic freedom in the united
states
and that's a lie it's a lie with
consequences suicide is up poverty is up
hunger is up millions of jobs are not
coming back anytime
soon in just a moment i'm going to give
you four reasons to lock down to our bad
policy and should stop
right this very minute if you are not
listening to this
with your raikon earbuds you really
should be click the link in the
description right now
to get 15 off your order first
lockdowns were designed to not overwhelm
the healthcare system not
to crush the virus we've been told that
lockdowns are necessary in order to
crush the virus but that is a
radical shift in what we were told
lockdowns were supposed to do
remember 15 days to slow the spread we
were told that the goal was to flatten
the curve
and we were shown this chart there were
two curves
one sharply rose and then just as
sharply fell the other stayed relatively
flat
the area under the two curves the number
of infections hospitalizations and
deaths was supposed to be the same
the difference was that the first curve
that higher curve would spike beyond the
capacity of the healthcare system like
we saw in italy so we locked down
we did it to flatten the curve this is
the point about bending the curve
a surge of cases will overwhelm hospital
capacity we must flatten this curve and
we must social distance
flattening the curve flatten the curve
flatten the curve
if we're able to flatten the curve when
you see that beautiful curve
that you're trying to flatten all the
time the phrase flatten the curve
flattening the curve flattening the
curve we flattened the curve
florida's flattened the curve that curve
is
flattening because we are flattening the
curve by what we are doing
we flattened the curve but as it turns
out flattening the curve wasn't
enough now we were told that lockdowns
could magically crush
the curve governors who reopened their
states were ripped to shreds for having
any curve at all and governors who had
already experienced a major spike in
covet and in some cases whose policies
had resulted in mass death were praised
for having crushed the curve
ronda sanchez in florida was torn apart
for allowing some beaches in florida to
remain open
despite the fact that beaches are one of
the safest places on the planet to be
safe from covet they are warm they're
out in the open
air and they are subject to lots of uv
light brian kemp of georgia said the
atlantic
was engaging in an experiment in human
sacrifice
for reopening doug ducey of arizona was
ripped up and down for allowing
reopening
so as gregg abbott of texas meanwhile
suspiciously jared palace of colorado
escaped scrutiny
despite pursuing similar policy could
that have had something to do with the
fact that palace was a democrat and the
others were republicans
it would be tough not to see the
hypocrisy in the media treatment of
lockdowns the media
ripped into people who wanted to go back
to work in fact they said that you just
wanted to kill the elderly
to get a haircut but if you're chicago
mayor lori lightfoot or speaker of the
house nancy pelosi
you are free to head out to the salon
and get a hair dry the media tore into
anti-lockdown protesters but dutifully
informed americans that if you were
protesting
against supposed systemic american
racism you're actually doing something
good
and positive for public health second
lockdowns don't crush the curve
lockdowns don't work there's no evidence
they crush the virus
in fact where the virus has already been
heavily seated lockdowns may actually
exacerbate the spread
according to donald luskin of trend
macro writing in the wall street journal
quote measuring from the start of the
year to each state's point of maximum
lockdown
which range from april 5th to april 18th
it turns out that lockdowns correlated
with a greater spread of the virus
states with longer stricter lockdowns
also had larger coveted outbreaks
the five places with the harshest
lockdowns the district of columbia new
york michigan new jersey and
massachusetts
had the heaviest caseloads a study in
the lancet journal in july found
similarly quote
a longer time prior to implementation of
any lockdown was associated with a lower
number of detected cases
this does seem counter-intuitive but the
data are the data
at best lockdowns may delay spread but
they don't crush it ask new zealand
where they lock down incredibly hard
and then head to lockdown again because
even in that isolated nation with like
seven people
there were cases from community spread
so what does crush the curve
the virus moving through a community
that's it european countries that locked
down originally
experienced a curve anyway there's a
common pattern to covet
where a lot of people have had covered
the virus doesn't seem to return where
lockdowns have been applied
covet appears when people open back up
this has nothing to do with politics
it's just
a simple reality northern italy was
crushed by coveted early on
now southern italy is spiking second
waves aren't really the problem
first waves are but first waves are
inevitable the only thing we can do is
slow the spread and protect the
vulnerable and the elderly
that's why it's so intensely stupid for
the media to credit andrew cuomo for his
treatment of covet in new york
cuomo self-aggrandizing even
created a poster
showing how he had crushed the curve
look at this thing it's ridiculous
he actually created a paper mache
mountain of death to demonstrate his own
wonderful policy decisions
and now he is writing a book on his
terrific handling of covit
it should be titled if i did it
meanwhile his own health department
seems to have conveniently lost all
statistics on the number of nursing home
patients who died in new york
due to cuomo's decision to ship covet
positive elderly patients back into
nursing homes here's the reality
cuomo blew it states that didn't lock
down didn't
social distancing may be effective at
slowing the spread in a free society
the evidence on masking is mixed given
that some heavily masked nations like
italy and the uk got creamed
while scandinavia which doesn't mask
didn't but full-scale lockdowns
aren't a solution to covet perhaps the
most insane part our political incentive
structure means that politicians are
given
credit for locking down under all
circumstances which is why manhattan
where there are virtually no cases and
no deaths now
remains locked down we'll get to more of
that in just one second but first
these yes
yes indeed your raycons my raycons
everybody's raycon
well they're not yours unless you go buy
them right now by clicking on the link
below these raikons are fantastic raycon
offers their wireless earbuds in a range
of fun colors and patterns they are
super comfortable they come with a
variety of fit options
the compact carrying case it can charge
earbuds four times on a single charge
unlike some of those other wireless
options raycon earbuds are stylish and
discreet
no dangling wires no stems they are
excellent for
video chats you know how many people
wear raycon celebrities like
cardi b are obsessed with ray-cons
look at this
these raycons right here look at this
my god the magnificence behold
blue steel and they fit in your ears
absolutely wonderfully and if they don't
then you can customize them
raycon earbuds start about half the
price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market
they sound just as amazing as the other
top audio brands you know raycons are
great for working from home and working
out listening to music and podcasts for
hours without driving your roommates
significant other children or neighbors
crazy and again those everyday e25
earbuds those are the ones you want six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass a more compact design
that gives you that nice noise isolating
fit it comes in new
fun colors not just blue steel but other
new and fun colors as well click the
link in the description below to get 15
off your order
third the costs of lockdown are
extraordinary both in terms of economic
cost and human life
the cost of lockdown insane
internationally the africa centers for
disease control and prevention surveyed
people in 20 african countries
they found that more than two-thirds
said they would run out of food and
water if they had to stay at home for 14
days the new york times reported in
april
that the lockdowns could create an
unprecedented hunger emergency
doubling the number of people facing
acute hunger to
million people by the end of the year
countries like spain and the uk have
reported second quarter gdp drops
exceeding 20 percent
the us did better but still dropped 10.6
percent as did germany
in the united states lockdown cost the
economy trillions of dollars
30 million jobs disappeared in the u.s
in just six weeks
after lockdown began a study from
well-being trust found that lockdowns
could lead to 75 000 deaths from suicide
and other deaths of despair dr scott
atlas of stanford professor john burge
of the university of chicago professor
ralph keaney of duke and professor
alexander lipton at hebrew university
found that for every month of lockdown
the american economy lost
1.1 trillion dollars in july the
washington post reported that 17 000
excess deaths due to factors other than
clovid were reported in just
illinois massachusetts michigan new york
and new jersey and that was just during
march
april and may and that's because people
weren't going to the hospital for other
conditions
by may over 100 000 small businesses
across the country had closed
permanently
furthermore because kova
disproportionately harms the elderly the
average age of death across the world is
about 80
the cost to other populations in terms
of lost years of life thanks to lockdown
that measures premature death against
life expectancy has far exceeded
the cost of covid atlas at all wrote
quote considering only the losses of
life from missed health care and
unemployment due solely to the lockdown
policy
we conservatively estimate that the
national lockdown is responsible
for at least 700 000 lost years of life
every month or about 1.5 million so far
already far surpassing the covet 19
total
children have been damaged by being
barred from schools despite the fact
that covet is significantly less deadly
to young children than the flu and the
fact that by most studies
children are not a chief transmission
vector for adults finally
lockdowns are not the only choice so far
the only solution to the virus is to
protect the vulnerable and then open up
we have been provided a false choice
completely open up or completely locked
down well there is a third choice
open with social distancing and other
precautions while protecting the
vulnerable the media enjoy
lying by omission while discussing
lockdown they pretend that young people
being diagnosed with covet is a grave
threat
it isn't unless they are transmitting to
others who are vulnerable they suggest
that case count is relevant
rather than hospitalizations and deaths
they pretend that vaccine developments
is the only solution
and we should stay locked down until
then none of that is true
we know social distancing can minimize
transmission of the disease
some research suggests masking can help
slow the spread of covet though the
evidence is mixed
we also know that the most important
thing is ensuring that the elderly and
vulnerable
you listening andrew cuomo are protected
from coven this means particularly
testing everyone who enters nursing
homes
more than 45 of all deaths from covet
have occurred in nursing homes and
assisted living facilities
and there is some good news here studies
suggest that pre-existing t-cell
immunity
means that many people will not get
covered or will be asymptomatic this has
led some scientists to speculate that
the actual rate of antibody presence
conferring a low level of community
spread might be 20 or 25
of a population rather than the 80 or 90
typically associated with herd immunity
here's what we certainly know where the
virus burns through it has not burned
through again
which suggests that protecting the
vulnerable slowing the spread so we
don't overwhelm the health care system
providing time for therapeutics and
getting back to work is the best
strategy
lockdown is the worst strategy lockdowns
are bad policy they were justifiable at
the beginning of the pandemic
because we didn't know anything about
covet but as time went on and the data
emerged politics overwhelmed
science that cannot be allowed to happen
again lockdowns have to end and they
have to end
right now goodbye